Speaker 1: 's go to Chris from
Massachusetts. Chris, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. Hello. So I
don't know if I ever got a chance to
congratulate you on the race against the
majority. Reporter To a million subscribers.
Speaker 1: Oh, my goodness. You're
saying from, like, a over a year ago?
Speaker 2: Over a year ago.
Speaker 1: Oh, well, thank you.
I appreciate the congratulations.
Speaker 2: The strategy of
stealing the set panels. Very effective.
Speaker 1: Yeah, because people thought
they were like, okay, wait a step. This is how
it worked. I stole Santas panels, right? So then
people who were subscribe to Sam would come across
my videos, they'd recognize the panels and go, Oh,
yeah, this is the this is the guy I'm subscribed
to. They would see, Wait, I'm not subscribed. I
must have gotten accidentally unsubscribed. They
would sub and I would basically trick them into
subscribing to me with my panels. It was genius.
Speaker 2: Brilliant. Yeah. But I wanted. I called
in to warn you. There is a new threat on the
horizon. In a man called Brian Tyler Cohen.
Speaker 1: Oh, is he getting panels?
Speaker 2: No. Well, I already noticed that
you already copied his frameworks. Mike, stand.
Speaker 1: Oh, no, no.
Speaker 2: Yes. I have never even seen his.
Speaker 1: Doesn't he use a lava leer? I've
never seen him use a boom Mike, actually.
Speaker 2: Oh, he uses a boom like.
Well, he copied like we need to.
Speaker 1: He copied my.
Speaker 2: Works.
All right. Okay, well, that will be decided.
But the next strategy. Yeah. Is we got to get
multiple cameras set up now. Oh, yeah. And we got
to go with a cleaner background, maybe dress you
in a suit instead of the zip up button up.
Speaker 1: I used to wear a suit. I got
off of it because it felt pedantic.
Speaker 2: Well, okay. Brian Tyler,
Colin, he's he is like, predicted to hit
2 million subscribers in like 2024. You're
not going to hit 2 million until 2027.
Speaker 1: Oh, my God. I'll be retired.
Speaker 2: Get to strategize together.
Speaker 1: Here,
let's work it out. I'm open to all ideas.
Speaker 2: Okay. All right. Good luck. I
gave you a couple couple tips there. I want to see
him implemented. Good strategy, moving the show to
New York, too, because I don't know if you knew
this, but during the big live event the majority
report was putting on in Boston, there was a
plot to steal back the panels. Is that right?
You did a little 4D chess move on them there.
Speaker 1: Wait, Sam did a show in Boston?
Speaker 2: Yeah, earlier this year. Oh, wow.
Speaker 1: Interesting. I didn't know or.
Speaker 2: Actually was at risk. I think
they might have done what, in New York and
rescheduled the Boston show. Oh, okay. But that
was like the main I think that was the main reason
they were coming to Boston in the first place.
Speaker 1: To steal the panels when they thought
when I was here back then. Oh, wow. Yeah, that's
crazy. Well, good thing I moved out of there.
Speaker 2: Of course.
Speaker 1: All right, Chris,
thank you very much. You initiate the call.
There's Chris from Massachusetts with a lot of
very, very interesting ideas that we're going to
look into, every single one of them very strongly